we're told a pick four lottery game
involves drawing four numbered balls
from separate bins each containing balls
labeled from zero to nine so there are
ten thousand possible selections in
total for example you could get a zero a
zero a zero and a zero a zero a zero a
zero and a one all the way up to nine
thousand nine hundred and ninety nine
four nines players can choose to play a
straight bet where the player wins if
they match all four digits in the
correct order
the lottery pays
five hundred dollars on a successful one
dollar straight bet
let x represent a player's net gain on a
one dollar straight bet
calculate the expected net gain
and they say hint the expected net gain
can be negative so why don't you pause
this video and see if you can calculate
the expected net gain
all right so there's a couple of ways
that we can approach this one way is to
just think about the two different
outcomes there's a scenario where you
win with your straight bet there's a
scenario where you lose with your
straight bet
now let's think about the net gain
in either one of those scenarios the
scenario where you win you pay one
dollar we know it's a one dollar
straight bet and you get forty five
hundred dollars so what's the net gain
so it's going to be forty five hundred
dollars minus one so your net gain is
going to be
four thousand four hundred and ninety
nine dollars
now what about the net gain in the
situation that you lose well in the
situation that you lose you just lose a
dollar so this is going to be
negative
one
dollar right over here
now let's think about the probabilities
of each of these situations
so the probability so the probability of
a win we know is one in ten thousand one
in
ten thousand and what's the probability
of a loss well that's going to be 9999
out of 10 000.
and so then our expected net gain is
just going to be the weighted average of
these two so i could write our
expected net gain is going to be
four thousand four hundred and ninety
nine
times the probability of that one in ten
thousand
plus negative one times this so that i
could just write that as minus
nine thousand nine hundred and ninety
nine over ten thousand
and so this is going to be equal to
let's see it's going to be four thousand
four hundred ninety nine minus nine
thousand nine hundred and ninety nine
all of that over
10
000
and let's see
this is going to be equal to
fifth negative 5500 over 10 000
negative
5500
over 10
000 which is the same thing as negative
55 over 100 or i could write it this way
this is equal to negative 55 hundredths
i could write it this way 0.55
so that's one way to calculate the
expected net gain
another way to approach it is to say all
right what if we were to get 10 000
tickets what is our expected net gain on
the 10 000 tickets
well we would
pay ten thousand dollars
and we would expect to win once it's not
a guarantee but we would expect to win
once so expect
4500
in payout
and so you would then let's see you
would have a net gain
of
it would be negative fifty five hundred
dollars negative fifty five
hundred dollars
now this is the net gain when you do 10
000 tickets now if you wanted to find
the expected net gain per ticket you
would then just divide by 10 000. and if
you did that you would get exactly what
we just calculated the other way
so anyway you try to approach this this
is not a great bet